and like Lynn Lippmann I was a student
in Paris in 1960 although i don't
remember the skinny dipping part that
was but i do remember vividly my
pressure of seeing breathless and the
impact that I made and I mean all over
Paris that's all people are talking
about was a booty souffle I also
remember the impact that the music made
Martius allows wonderful jazz score and
one striking think me about the Dodds
films musically is that they brought a
whole new vision of how music could be
used in films poem is Rocky's score for
alphaville which was a very stunning
Chaz oriental skoura very intense but a
can turn on a dime on a heartbeat and
suddenly become the most tender of
expressions as yours delarue's very
beautiful haunting a string orchestra
score it was very unique at the time for
our contempt no one had ever used music
the way he hadn't filmed for me I found
that some of his his music played a
character in the screen those more than
just scoring is more than underscoring I
felt that some of the some of the scores
the music was actually like literally
character that would offer commentary
and there was one of the striking things
for me his films opened our eyes and
ears to what the possibilities were and
I think we're all better for it who make
films thank you
you